I urge the government of Israel to
exercise maximum restraint the
international response has been bizarre
at best I mean at the moment Israel is
doing what it's got to do and it has uh
some uh International backing behind it
uh but Justin Trudeau who who literally
was was closing people's bank accounts
who were protesting against him in
Canada who is no moral Arbiter of
anything uh here's what he had to say
just a few days ago about Israel's
action in
Gaza the human tragedy that is unfolding
in Gaza is
heart-wrenching especially the suffering
we see in and around the alifa hospital
I have been clear that the price of
Justice cannot be the continued
suffering of all Palestinian
civilians even Wars have
rules all innocent life is equal in
worth Israeli and
Palestinian I urge the government of
Israel to
exercise maximum
restraint as the world is
watching on TV on social media we're
hearing the testimonies of doctors
family members
survivors kids who've lost their parents
the world world is witnessing this the
killing of women and
children of
babies this has to
stop he is gener he is evil I don't know
how to put it any other way he he is
evil who the hell does he think he is
that he can tell another Western
democracy how they should defend their
men women and children mayor can you
talk a little bit about the things that
Israel actually has done like dropping
leaflets and things of that nature and
the things that Hamas has done to
maximize uh civilian casualties maybe
that'll Enlighten Justin Trudeau just a
little bit I mean if you would like me
to talk about it we're never going to
end this show but I think I think
there's something that's this is this is
actually a scary Trend to talk about
because I think we're going to see more
and more of this people who came out at
the beginning being all like oh we
support Israel support Israel but then
the the issue with this is really the
fact that he is is putting the
responsibility on Israel I mean
Netanyahu responded to this tweet but I
to not we'll get to that in a moment but
I think that I think that Israel has
gone above and beyond um you know the
truth is Israel could have completely
blitzed and bom bombed all of Gaza in
the first three days and we would have
this whole thing would have been over we
have the military capacity and yet you
could say it's because of the hostages
but I don't think that's true I think
it's also true I think it's to do with
the fact we actually value human human
life and Kamas does not and that is the
basis of all actions and the fact that
there are people in the west who still
are not capable of understanding that
the responsibility for every single
civilian casualty in this entire war
from beginning to endes with one group
and one group only and that is Kamas to
point the fingers on Israel and to say
to them to hold to have restraint it's
not just idiotic it's pathetic and I
think you need to ask yourself as a
leader of a country what would you do
what would you do like really you you
would hold restraint more to the fact I
don't see somebody like just and Trudeau
ask like putting his skin in the game
and offering for the gazin to come live
in Canada no they're just happy to sit
and watch by and say this is what Israel
is doing wrong and this is how Israel
should act they hav't he hasn't visited
he hasn't seen and he just he's a
populist and he drives me
insane am me I don't think I have to ask
you a question just talk about Justin
Trudeau sure sure I think I know how to
get him on Israel's side all we have to
do is tell him that Kamas is not
vaccinated um exactly Simple Solution he
would turn against them in a second um
you know and not to throw another
impression into it but I heard Jordan
Pederson describ Justin judau as pure
Persona you
know and and it didn't he's pure Persona
you know it's like well um the balls in
your yeah in your courtroom he it didn't
take very long for the lip service of
being a Western pro-israel Country
allied with Israel to completely fall on
its face I want to read BB's response to
Justin Trudeau he tweeted this out he
said it is not Israel that is
deliberately targeting civilians but
Hamas that beheaded burned and massacred
civilians in the worst Horrors
perpetrated on Jews since the Holocaust
while Israel is doing everything to keep
civilians out of Harm's Way Hamas is
doing everything to keep them In Harm's
Way Israel provides civilians in Gaza
humanitarian corridors and safe zones
Hamas prevents them from leaving at
gunpoint it is Hamas not Israel that
should be held accountable for
committing a double War crime targeting
civilians while hiding behind civilians
the forces of civilization must back
Israel in defeating Hamas barbarism do
you think that there's also an inherent
asymmetry in that Israel is the only
country that's ever asked to explain
themselves and perhaps if one day they
just decided not to explain themselves
anymore like everybody else that it
actually might behoove them in a weird
way yeah I know I find that Israel in a
way is in this abusive relation ship
with the Western world that condemns
them and to the extent that they cave to
it and enable it and try to Showcase
that they're better in that sense they
only get further punished for
it